my dad's the greatest dude I ever met my  life and he had a temper anytime  anything broke in the house five minutes  into fixing it he was bitching about his  marriage  when people talk about finding your  comedic voice Bill Burr's name is at the  top of that list but he didn't start  there here he is talking about the same  topic at two different points in his  career was whenever you like broke  something because my dad my dad would  totally flip out right but the words he  used he would actually thought it was a  good thing you know I mean like you  break a window she'd be like nice  real nice  oh that's beautiful the early bird has a  more playful sarcastic voice but the  Burr we know today my dad was like that  my dad's the greatest dude I ever met my  life and he had a temper anytime  anything broke in the house five minutes  into fixing it he was bitching about his  marriage  [ __ ] screwdriver I swear to God I  don't want the [ __ ] I ever got married  for